hey everybody it's Monday welcome to
meab bit I'm here with Mary kiss you
know her hi hi uh we're going to play
one of your favorite games today which
is Hakuna matada hakun Matata we're
going to play Lion King yeah we're going
to play the Sega Genesis version of Lion
King yay um and Mary's going to do most
of the playing she's actually really
good at this game I'm not I have some
experience some childhood experience
yeah I'll be using mostly my wit and um
most if not all of my cunning you also
know the music better than I do so
you're going to be
singing I know a few I know a few
Tunes uh yeah so yeah here we go um
Disney made a lot of great games for the
Genesis and Super Nintendo and a lot of
people like to argue over which you know
console had the better version oh man we
were practicing on the Super Nintendo
version of this last night and playing
on Genesis now I'm immediately noticing
that it doesn't look as
good yeah this is a sweet version I
obviously am super biased I had Sega
growing up so this was like the only
thing we had access to and we didn't
have a lot of games so like when we did
have something we had to play the crap
out of it so this was something that
even though you know I was too young to
like be really good at it we played it
until eventually we beat it and it took
a really long time and most of my older
sisters helped yeah cuz this game is
really hard at least from what I've
played it gets a lot harder the hit
boxes are interesting I think like we
were noticing when we were setting it up
Peter was like is there something wrong
with the jump I was like nope that's
just the way it is like the jump is
pretty it's got a real nice delay on
it um but you know this is like a game
that you know just especially for like
heaven heavy nostalgia people this is
like this is way up there everybody
loves this game this is actually made by
Westwood Studios the guys who used to do
command and conqueror back in the day
he's stuck in the Rock oh he is isn't
he this is the first of many amazing
things about the Genesis version of this
game I'm really excited to show you
guys I actually can't stand on that rock
because it'll hurt
me yeah ah okay I can't roll into those
I don't know so uh a lot of you guys if
you've played this before might be like
we are all the secrets in this level
there's a few there's a few I know a few
of you were thinking Mary where are
those Secrets where are those secrets
well let me show you a few of these
secos so there's actually a secret in
the secret which is so
genesa right so there's extra this um
that sun is a
continue uh so those are definitely
pretty valid valuable to have oh
no um and then there's different bugs
that not just like replenish your health
but they actually give you more Health
those are the really good ones to have I
think they're rainbow and then they're
these big blue bugs that increase your
Roar meter I'm actually not sure how
valuable that is but I think later on
maybe it's more important so here's a
blue bug that'll increase my Roar this
is why we need instruction manuals
because there's no telling what these
bugs do except from your experience yeah
there's and even that is a bit of a oh
for god sakes bit of a stretch so my
Roar should like put them in a stun
State because they're so afraid of how
manly I am yeah I do that a lot um in
real life as well it's really beneficial
it's amazing right before you fight
someone if you roar at them that they
just freeze for like a few seconds giv
you ample time to punch them in the face
get they don't get it dude it's like
they did not learn at
all um I remember when I was a kid that
the fact that the leaves came out of the
trees when you jumped on them I was like
it's so real like it's so real like look
at that look at those
leaves um and then if you want this bug
you actually have to jump at it because
you start rolling before you can get it
top tip top tip or Pro
tip
Boop I'mma Boop you come here
worst enemy in the game yeah two hits
what boss Takes Two Hits I know and
what's funny is when you become an adult
um when you become the adult Simba it
actually gets harder you have to Maul
them several times and hit them this is
one of those
uh mini games in the uh the more bugs
you get the more Bon bonuses you get you
can get more continues more extra lives
um it gets a lot harder but luckily I'm
really good I missed it so that's not
too bad that's good that's it's the best
you've done so far yeah 24 is pretty
good I've done worse this is kind of
like the famous level in the game the
one with the giraffes of the demon
giraffes whenever anyone talks about
this game they're like those [__]
monkeys dude [__] monkeys it's it is
hard I I definitely I practiced it last
night because I forgot how hard it
actually is but it it is doable I beat
it before and I I'll beat it again darn
it so all right the secret with the
monkeys is if they're pink you can roar
and hit
them and when you roar it changes their
position and then they'll throw you the
proper
way that should do
it when I was a kid I mean I understand
that this was like their version of a
puzzle
but like for a kid we didn't know what
we were doing and we were just
constantly stuck there for hours not
sure what to do just doing random stuff
we had no idea what we were supposed to
be doing it's [__]
game that one's actually really hard too
A lot of people get stuck on the ostrich
um the trick is and people always wonder
why they die there you have to get the
ostrich through not Simba so the goal is
to make sure the ostrich gets through
the two birds nests if you do that then
symbol will get through much
easier another uh top tip for
you all right that's kind of one of the
harder parts so I have two options here
I think you can actually climb onto
those noses the nose holes of the hippos
that have zero animation um or you can
swing on the butt
oh I should have died but I
didn't I [__] up sorry I'm going going
have to bleep that you're only getting
away with this because you're what like
the prince of the jungle as it were yeah
they kind of let me do whatever I want
even big POS um this is like in the game
they really shortened the crap out of
the movie in the G in in the movie this
is where I'm singing about how I'm going
to be the best King and everyone can s
my D um is basically the gist of it I
believe
um no I believe you knew how that song
goes Peter I know YouTube knows I don't
I'm going to be a mighty king So enemies
beware that's all I know I think by
enemies she means
bugs got to watch out for them bugs and
uncles oh always watch out for uncles
these painted simbas are the save states
for each game which are good to
know
enemies loud as it Beast so little
hair main event
was up I'm looking down I'm working on
my an inspiring
thing what just can't wait to be
king you should just come on every week
and sing Lion King songs even though
we're not playing Lion King you should
just sing these
songs Oh Nala she was she was a baller
when I was a kid everybody liked
Nala around all
day we'll do it all my way that's how
you got to sing it like this finger in
the air you have to
um be pretty fancy about about
it little horn bills for he's kind of a
little punk in this movie that's what
I'm saying he's a piece of [__] so to
get back I actually have to get on these
logs you got to imagine like this game
was targeted at kids that were how old
were you when you played this like 81
yeah I was young I don't know what they
were thinking ter of I'm surprised I
mean again I think when I beat this game
it was like my older
sisters showing me um and I would get
really frustrated easily with things
that I'm able to do now because now that
I'm um a smart adult before it was like
really hard for me to do
that all right so I actually do need to
fix that monkey that's the secret is
that even though I already fixed that
monkey before I got to fix him again
um so now that I've gotten my one up I
will recorrect that monkey and I believe
now that this order of the monkey should
should get me to the next
area um I hope you're all mightily
impressed all right cool uh bug hunt
stage this is different than the other
one with Pumba this one I'm just kind of
running around but I can't get any of
the spiders or the level's over so
you'll so it's probably best to just not
even come close to them cuz sometimes
you'll you'll get closer to them even
though you think that oh
twofer so DM hork was in he was out of
high school when this game came out wow
he's old this game will age
people all right so this is actually one
of the harder levels I think
um it's the first one that has um a lot
of death traps this is kind of like
where you're no longer a child in the
game anymore it's got evil things this
bug will actually hurt you uh I don't
know it's just the first life lesson of
many in The Lion King is that you can't
just go around eating bugs willy-nilly
they're not all there to help you but
Mary I love bugs well this game can
teach you what your parents could never
do because they died oh oh God that made
me
sad just get tired
there's a secret up here is a good bug
cool again how would you know um cuz he
says cool when I get it yeah but
beforehand right Peter I don't think you
heard me I said he said it was cool
um there's some Secrets I actually am
not fully aware of how to get yet which
is sad I know I to get some but not
everything uh
chickens are really annoying I know
they're vultures but they look like
fried chickens when you kill them so we
used to always call them
chickens I'm just going to play this by
the book my childhood
book come on you st
vulture he got me got me Peter he got me
Peter
Brown are you going to say anything yeah
I'm looking at the background there are
so many dead
animals this is a really dark game yeah
another Secret huhuh
Peter good
job you're so proud of your secrets I'm
just impressed that you can even beat
this game it I'm surprised too I didn't
think I could but yesterday after a few
hours of practice I did do it so you'll
notice there's good bugs and then
there's bad bug to the right so you only
want to get the good
bugs another one of those
evil somewhere on the internet there has
to exist like a bug guide for Lion King
kind of like into the wild where it's
like what you know leaves of three Let
It Be type things
die
um I just kind of learned from
experience if they're darker colored
there's like two maybe three bugs that I
know now not to eat most of them are
like golden colored and it seems easy
enough I didn't find a bug guide but I
did find an advertisement for an old
Nestle ice cream cool creations Lion
King bug pops it was like a what' you do
you just mess
up anyway I died and not only did I die
but I died like an inch away from a save
state so now I have to do all everything
I just did all over again which is
really annoying sorry guys Lion King
what about those pops tell me about them
pops yeah you could buy Lion King theme
ice cream pops that had bugs in the
middle sounds great get away from
me wasn't did they make a sequel to Lion
King but it was about Timone and Pumba
the whole time oh man I don't oh oh no
they made a show there was like a TV
show I remember the Tbone and Pumba show
I don't remember racy it's so hard to
jump the jump is like slightly delayed
I'm sorry guys I'm really messing it up
I'm just going to try to run through
this I got to jump earlier than I want
to [__] you
God yeah you have to like fight your
instincts When
jumping I just jump earlier than
you'd think so I'm just going to keep
making that noise too I should have died
there did you see that so that bird can
like continuously attack me it's a pain
in my
butt gestures do you want to sing
another song uh I know you do
oh it was called Lion King
half what a show I think the
movie I remember the Timone and Pumba
show I think they had a
show oh Lion King 2 in a half I don't
like
that wait there was Lion King to Simba's
Pride that was where he had a daughter I
did it I got to the save Sate yeah so
this green goo starts coming after after
you as soon as you're on the Rocks I got
to high tail It Go Go Lon King 2 has a
33% rating on look so
silly
running that happened to me in practice
that's how bad I am at the Game
Stop I hate you do you want to do a save
state so you don't fall down yeah I do
all right so down and start we're using
the we're cheating yeah we're using the
Retron 5 which got built save sa
functionality
no do it on Save State gotcha yeah did I
do it you did it did it break the game
no it's Head Start I'm going to break
the game I'm so good yeah Lion King one
and a half was the straight also known
as The Lion King 3 which is totally not
confusing all right so oh [__] I'm so
bad all right come jump at me you kind
of got to trick them into jumping at you
so they get tired and then you can
squish them oh my God so
bad Okay so they should both be booped I
think there is there one more down
here oh my God these vultur are so
irritating they're terrible
creatures Bo all right so here's a secro
for you guys if you drop down stop it oh
is that another secret yeah yeah there's
a one up up there but I'll get that
later so if you drop well I didn't do
that correctly but if you drop down you
get um another continue State and you
can actually jump through the bouncy
thing I'm like I'm spitting and then you
can double jump into the bouncy thing I
believe oh I broke it get the Save State
though I didn't do it right just load
your Save State but then I all right you
don't have a choice now now I'm upset a
to load the state well this is
incredibly convenient and
cheating kids don't cheat don't cheat
stop it I hate these
things oh my God I think I killed him by
default he like jumped
off shoot all right so now I got to kill
these stupid buies
again I hate killing vultures they're so
boring all
right stop it stop
it okay I can do it this is going to be
a good
one all right you you are supposed to be
able to double jump onto there but now I
feel like I can't do
it it's okay we've got six lives bunch
of continues we should be good uh I
forget how sorry guys die die okay if
you fall there which happens yeah you
start from the beginning of the game
that's the beginning of the game the
beginning of the whole game it's the
game of the this the beginning of the
level I just start and go all the way
around again well it's only the second
level so it's kind of like starting over
come on I hate you
guys oop oh my God I'm going to
die oh my God I'm going to die
oh no another one come on let be
convenient how many were there in the oh
man Mary jez I'm sorry guys it's really
hard I should have made another Save
State we don't really need all those
continues and stuff right so you can
just kind of Forge ahead Oh you mean
because the cheating
yeah good
news you see a peck at me little
wiener the odds are stacked against you
little prince
that sounds like something a non Prince
would say I'm talking to the prince like
a a
commoner I'm okay with being a commoner
all right I'm still going to get that
continue no I'm
not I've had a change of
heart all
right I did
it I cheated
again I don't even feel bad about it
look we've only got an hour to play
right and I expect you're going to beat
it
I it's we're only 20 minutes in I can
get pretty close I think I'll definitely
get to the problem is is there's this
lava level and lava like falls from the
ceiling and it's actually really hard
and not oh my God not only oh I'm going
to
die not only did I have to cheat but I
had to cheat like severely in terms of
like getting a Save State all the time
to like function through it I don't know
how I did it as a
kid another bug toss give me them bugs
we got a bug toss coming up it's a bug
toss so there is a bad bug in here
that's oh he dropped a one up did you
see that um it's got like wings I missed
one um and that also ends your your bugs
but I got a one up that was is pretty
cool right yeah Stampede this is a very
famous
level um I believe it's gone down in
history is one of the greatest levels of
all time I think somebody said that at
some point um somebody great yeah I
think someone important it puts probably
me I I remember one of the interesting
things about this level is there's rocks
that come out and they blink for 4
seconds which you'd always count to
three and and I it's
four and it's very misleading you almost
always what's coming question mark you
don't
know 1 2 3 4 see like it's so annoying
like you have to well it's a fast count
but you know what I mean 1 2 3
um oh he got me this is before
is this spoiler alert is this before or
after the father
death oh this is right before because
the father dies during this yeah he dies
like they they really skip a lot of the
story uh but this is the very important
scene where that guy commits suicide in
the Bramble
patch so this is kind of one of the more
annoying levels I'll show you why it's
because of that Falling Rocks those
falling Lo rocks fall throughout the
entire entire
gameit it just seems really fair
and it doesn't matter you cannot protect
yourself there's nothing you can do you
just [__] have to you just have to
avoid them as best you can seriously
it's Anno hey guys this game isn't hard
enough let's just put rocks in that you
can't defend yourself from how about
that secret sound good sound good um and
like yeah like you could be
oh my gosh this is an important
part did you guys see that just want to
make sure you saw it
Peter yeah I saw it a a a a In the
Jungle the M jungle the lion sleeps
tonight oh you son of a [__] in the
jungle
jungle I I think I think it's the same
line s tonight
yeah you're just getting pummeled by
rocks that's a part of the story oh my
God I'm going to
die a p
away oh my God I'm going to die should I
do a Save State I can't not with this
low of
Health I got to make
it those rocks I think you got it those
rocks where is the save there it
is
die you're doing really well it's really
sad when you die like that oh my gosh
fine I'll just how did you die though
because they were both on their back
well if you don't land on top of them
and you land the side of
them I can see how it's a shitty game
that's the answer I was looking for okay
that is that what you wanted me to say
Peter this game's awesome but it has
weird hit boxes and these um the the
area in which you're allowed to like
actively hold on to something is really
small and it's so easy to fall in this
section I know it seems like it's easy
because I'm playing it but it's actually
really
hard it's mostly yeah like the timing in
the hit box boxes to make everything so
difficult but we accept it why we I
accepted it because it was the only game
that I had at the time besides um Sega
Aladdin which I also played the crap out
of and we should play on this
show meab bit on Mondays at 11:00 a.m.
oh you son of
a all right this is the end what are
they playing on multiple players today
you know if you ever come back we'll
kill
you if you ever come back we'll kill you
oh man that's such a good voice I love
that guy's
voice say that g say that name it gives
me chills mua do it again mu mu mu
mua so many bugs I'm so good at this
game why don't you give me a challenge
oh my God he give me a challenge
like a that's pretty good 29 pretty good
29 pretty good if you can get in the 30s
that's really good auna mat a auna mat
all right I'm going to do should I do a
safe State no it's good yeah all right
so you want to go all the way to the
right uh some people are going to be
like you don't get bugs if you do that
Mary doesn't matter uh I'm not looking
for bugs life's not all about bugs you
know I oh
you
frog um I personally think these levels
this is when it Jesus starts to get
really hard there's all sorts of stuff
that hits you and if you ask me unless
the bug um son of a uh increases your
health so it's not just replenishing it
but it makes the bar bigger it's not
worth getting um because it it's just
better to finish the level at this stage
so if you go all the way to the right
um if you go all the way to the right
it's the fastest way to get to the edge
of the level which is what I personally
want is to finish the game right I
actually need that bug so I'm going to
get this Save State and then eat that
bug and then do this all over
again you see how excited he was to go
on that like most cats he couldn't wait
for the water
level I hate those frogs spider I think
is over here okay so again I'm going to
go all the way to the right oh you he
was waiting for me mother you son of a
[__] uh this uh is kind of I don't know
how well known it is but I swear like a
lot of people have problems with this
log area it's really hard to get up
especially when you're a kid cuz you can
easily not jump enough or jump too much
and you just die so the trick is this
area of logs has a log you can jump to
the next log if you're under it so you
just
jump to the to like straight up from
that log and then you can easily climb
um there should be a oneup coming up on
the right
oh
mama um this was like one of the bane of
my childhood when like this section
because it's so hard to not die here oh
my gosh I'm not
climbing here we
go and if you go for the one up which
clearly I'm going to you risk you know
doing the whole darn thing over
again I got
it oh the
anxiety all right so to get past this
you just have to get over this I'm so
close here we go here we go now I'm up
uh you cannot keep climbing I tried it
there's no more screen if you want to
redo this section to go after that bug
you can um I'm going to give you a big
fat screw that in fact I'm going to save
State cuz I hate doing that
again
um I think he
spits
the way he's looking at that spider I
don't like it I don't like the way that
spider looks and then coming
up I believe is the monkey which is kind
of like an annoying thing to deal with
well known in this game so he throws
coconuts at you and if you get too close
to him he'll smack you one good
um and it's actually how do you actually
get rid of him though oh you have to
every time you hit him with a coconut he
moves but look how close he is and it's
so hard to not oh he smacked me smacked
me good so I'm I might die because I'm
running out of life you need a like
pretty much full life to kill him
because he keeps throwing mother fing
coconuts at you stop stupid monkey dud
just doesn't give a [__] he's so many
Cocos you'd rather give up his COC did
you see what he just did yeah all right
I'm probably going to die rest assured I
will come back for this monkey so he you
should save state right now cuz you've
made it pretty far no cuz I I can't cuz
I only have one health bar left so if I
save it here and I chances are I'm going
to die and that attitude well it's
really hard to not get hit by by one
smack one smack a doodle is totally
normal go
oh damn so he's probably going to smack
me all right I anticipated this would
happen I'm going to come back with a
with a Vengeance all right uh while Mary
tries to figure this out we're going to
go to Quick ad break we'll be right back
stay tuned for more
megabit what are you trying what are you
trying to say oh we're back that's is
that what you're trying to tell
me
hey welcome
back this will be the last time I'm ever
on this
show okay no but you are good at that
though you should just do that okay
now
oh all right so I'm doing really good
this is good so I will get smack one
good here cuz it's just imp it's got to
I actually don't know how you do it
without you have to go to like the very
edge probably way
it's okay that was good that was good
all right so he's going to jump up jump
back down jump up there so this should
be the
end of Dos monkey I got to hit him two
more times so there's
one oh my God see look how close he is
toam me how do you even I'm supposed I'm
probably going to die again this sucks
you have to to the right of him yeah
clearly but how do you I'm going to I
he's going to smack me getting over
there and he's probably going to smack
me again and I'm going to
die you son of a
monkey you got it oh
no and now you're
dead I have a load
State because I'm a horrible person yeah
I'm going to get this monkey I want you
guys to know that this monkey will
die this I promise you I made one grave
air when I got hit with that coconut oh
oh
jeez
woo
no you
guys I've gotten where you did you see
that
frog that frog is spit on
me
frog I didn't even think frogs spit is
that like a
thing I know camels do and they
certainly don't spit in the in the movie
I've never heard of that oh my God I got
smack one good so I got
to so he smack me twice it's not very
good it's probably enough to finish
the game but I can't get smacked here
okay all right I should be able to do it
oh that was
close all right
so same
thing he's going to smack me good all
right all right I'm on the right
side oh
no he smacked me
twice
no
let me give it a try I'm going to [__]
up but let me give it a try I don't know
what I'm doing so you need to go down
though right yes you need to go down
it's a good sign waiting for this frog
to spit it's not going to spit you
won't all right so you need to
roll which is with the B button it's
forward and down okay forward and
down there you go oh did you hit him
yeah I didn't know you could do that
nope maybe that's how you're supposed to
get him in those really short areas so
when he smashes the ground you have to
jump wait so it's not down and jump It's
how do you roll again it's down and B
down no it's not down and forward you
have to hit B no you don't press any
buttons to
roll I'm hitting weird this game is
weird
h h
that's um all I can you cannot duck
under the coconut no I was trying I was
trying to roll it's weird you got to you
think you have to double tap forward and
yeah you have to be running that's why
it's not just forward and down damn it
it is what the
hell okay so it sounds like is it now
like when he's about to do
that cuz it it's not when he's throwing
cies cuz he'll he'll slap you one good
see see what a jerk man he slap you this
giant meaty
Paws all right I got this oh my
God that
frog is going to be the death of
me I'm [__] freak out I'm I'm
freaking
out all right I got it this is the one
you guys this is where the monkey gets
it that is not
representative all right so I'm going to
do what we were discussing I'm going to
jump over the coconuts and then when he
throws his hissy fit I'm going to jump
on
him all
right all right I feel pretty good you
guys I'm just going to jump over these
Kies throw your his see
fit not doing so hot okay I still got I
think I got two left two kills two kills
maybe so I think I can do
it I might just hang here for a
while you think eventually I'm monkey
would just get bored and [__] off he's a
[__] piece of
[__] okay I'm in trouble I'm in trouble
I am in
trouble I fully admit that this is not
good I miscalculated the coconut clearly
dude if anyone's going to do it it's
going to be me whoa hold
on you got to wait till he slammies he's
going to smack smack you one good he was
smacking you even when we waited for him
to
slam see screwing with me now there it's
right after he slam
jams slam a
jamama watch out he almost gave me the
hand woo good job
Peter I can't take down a simple
monkey as far as monkeys go he's pretty
advanced
I feel like I don't give monkeys enough
credit
yeah oh he got you double oh you're I'm
just going to skip him can I just skip
him actually after that point no you
have he's a boss so you have to kill him
to advance so the little just ends when
he dies you can't just keep going no so
there's this animation when he dies um
where he slams into the son of a [__]
when he slams into the
ground um
um oh I can't believe that hit my
tail
um and then
what this game is some
[__] um there's an animation where
he slams the ground and then the ground
disappears under him and he's like oh no
and his like little butt falls
down it's so
classic anyway
um that's how you proceed so you have to
get to that
state I agree
it's what I if anyone's going to beat
him it's going to be you I bopped him
one good I'm sick of
sick like some how could some of those
coconuts hurt you and
then getting good
uh all right all right I'm in a good
spot you can just get him right now with
the coconut you don't even have to [__]
around well then I have to accurately
roll without any
error get up get does he even do the
slamming if you're not standing up there
he will he will if he
knows I got him I got him I got him I
got him I got him all right so he does
his thing and then the ground disappears
look at that posture w
dead monkey Looney Tunes all right so
now I'm an adult this is adult Simba so
I'm grown up now so I can't uh I can't
roll anymore um but I did acquire this
additional bat technique so now I have
the Y button which I didn't have before
and I can stand up and bat um I can also
have my regular swipe so I have two
swipes I have a massive Roar and I jump
higher where was that like cut scene
that told us what happened
so there are zero Jaguars in the movie
but you will find that there are jaguars
in the game the fastest way to kill them
is to just get them on the ground and
then Maul their face off
oh I feel like he's a better cat than
you shut up there's a way to do it but I
messed up clearly but I will show you um
these Vines you have to
bat
oh um this is a good part those
monkeys throw rocks at you and they're
really annoying I don't think those are
rocks Mary oh my God my
childhood
no they've been finging poo this whole
time I've had so much poo hit me
PL Samurai
shampoo
um but you can kill the oh you can kill
the
monkeys with your Mighty Roar and you
can also bat them
watch yeah they're really
weak oh you son of a like I could see
why they'd be threatened by you because
you're sort of like the top of you know
the food chain in Africa but you're not
like exercising any sort of discretion
here you are just killing everything in
your path if it's in my way I absolutely
I'm going to kill it je what do you
think everyone is like throwing poop at
you all right I'm trying to figure this
out there is so there's there's like a
downward mall that works pretty good on
these Jaguars I think I might save cuz
this is actually kind of a hard part do
you dismal them save see the problem
with it is that there's like 10 Jaguars
and you have to beat them for this to to
move
on so if I miss any of them the whole
family comes after me and it's a big
pain in the wiener so I
just die look I'm how many Jaguars are
in this tiny tunnel and then Rafiki
shows me the way unless you want a
secret oh you stupid
monkey I assume there's a secret up here
there was a secret I must have got that
I don't know what if the secret is just
that there's a monkey up
there I think there's
a
oh monkey hate those monkeys no kidding
you're killing them left and right I
have an issue with monkeys so the other
song I know from the game is um do do
you remember the part where Timone and
Pumba need to come up with a distraction
for the
um hyenas because they he needs to get
scar alone and they're like will help
you uhhuh um so they get they dress and
drag and he says what do you want me to
do dress and drag and do the hoola and
then you CH
just and he goes
L remember I I can't be more every time
you bring these up I remember them but
like off the top of my head like I only
know as much as you're the guy's like L
if you're looking for a fat hunky juicy
meat eat my buddy Pumba here cuz he's a
tasty treat all you want to dine on a
tasty swine all you got to do is get in
line oh you aen uhhuh for some bacon yep
yep yep he's a big pig yep yep you could
be a big pig
too like that is good that is pretty
good that was also pretty
good this gives me such highs and such
lows do you remember the bird's name the
bird um is it toucan I believe oh Zazu
Zazu get rocked good one Eric who got
rocked is it me you got rocked
oh die die die die I'm just going to bat
at him from this this is kind of a weak
you got a turbo button you can just put
it in the middle and hold that down look
at
this such fantastic game
design all right I got to kill this
monkey again all right so yeah what
happened was when I hit the boulder if
the boulder comes anywhere
near
that monkey stupid monkey reckon your
life with turd since
1993 that monkey and I have had some
issues I can't believe I had to go this
far there's like no save states like you
see how far I got since the last time I
saved and I
die die and I like oh
Poo
okay all right this is a continue up
here see that
sun I'm the king of the jungle
poo my only
weakness what that should have killed
all of you
die
all right how much life do I have I
should probably save again wouldn't
hurt all right you guys I'm getting
pretty pretty close to like the really
huh oh you got me I'll slap you one good
Save State
finally like you think they put a little
few more of those in this level oh [__]
um I'm just batting at him piece by
piece here um you'll notice that they
get tired um when they start panting
like that if I do a roll move um I'll
just roll
them uh uh out of the level they kind of
like roll and then fall off the screen
it's kind of weird all right this is an
important part here we
go just like that movie just like in a
lion king where I'm trying to get that
Priceless artifact and that ball comes
after
me
jagie or I'll show you oh that's not
what I wanted to do I'm almost dead you
don't have a lot of life left there's a
lot of poo coming your way in your
future oh my
God die oh my God that monkey could have
killed
me got to survey the land
here
I feel like that's amazing for a lion to
do I haven't been to a circus in years
but I'm pretty sure oh you did you see
my epic jump to avoid that turd and then
I got hit
anyway
oh
monkey
oh I hate monkeys
monkeys are the they just want to share
their poo with you I don't want their
poo but they they don't know
that they're trying to appease the great
king I hate monkey with the only thing
they have to offer it I think this is a
secret up
here yeah so now my Roar is even bigger
and I'm still not sure of its value but
my Roar is
massive
monkey
monkeys all right this is another
another Jaguar
State you want the turbo button on do it
behind my oh my God so good atame so
good
Rafiki okay so this is an important part
this is where if you remember the
movie I look into a puddle of water you
see see and I see my dead father oh you
see your dead father I don't remember
the movie then all
right you see yourself you said you said
into a puddle you said you look into a
puddle that's what you do that's a cloud
bugs he comes in the clouds like when
you're in the plains you're in the cloud
what do you guys know about the cloud
he's in the cloud I'm the
cloud oh my God I'm in the
cloud oh I hit a spidey okay this is the
hardest prepared this is the hardest
level in the game it's it's incredibly
difficult honest to God it sucks it's a
shitty level it's poorly made everything
hurts you this acid constantly
drips oh my everything hurts you
everything everything kills you I'm
going to die
W um one of the more annoying things are
those bats um the
will continuously attack you oh my god
I've actually found that it's better to
just to just run through it honest to
God that's how hard it
is because there's a life thing up here
I think I think I have to kill him first
oh
bats bats let me give it a shot sure
it's hard so if you attack I think I
have a less I think personally you have
a less likelihood of survival oh the is
it the Y button or the B button oh it's
y it's
B what the bat button is yeah no so your
new SWAT is why why is really good
against bats because you can jump and
SWAT you cannot jump and hit but you can
jump and
SWAT you cannot jump on their heads no
I'm trying to jump and SWAT you're going
to die you can't do it you can I was
just trying to do it you can prove it do
you remember the last time we had this
conversation and you were like oh you
can
okay I swear this
game you just took
it it wasn't too bad it's just I feel
like most
animals will hurt you at least once and
there's so many in this level
there's so many
things that it's actually better to I
think just run through it honest to God
oh my
God oh my God run run you wiener run
like a
coward
Run Okay so the the bat should be
coming so all I have to do is kill this
guy and then I think there's either a or
a Save
State oh acid oh Mary it was a good show
it was it was a good show until
then I I'm going to do it I can I can
get better fudge
die I'd really like to get through that
beginning part without getting hit once
that would be
fantastic what the hell is the timing
like for that jumping SWAT
oh
shitty oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
run oh this is good this is really good
I'm such a coward oh my God die die die
die die the bats the bats the
bats all right did we have a Save State
recently I don't think so no that was a
mistake
do you want to do a Save State
now how am I not getting this SWAT done
oh sorry it's B it's B jump and that's
why it wasn't working Dam blame will
blame the game you told me no I'm
blaming you you told me it was why the
whole time don't blame the game I'm
blaming you Mary don't hate I'm not
blaming the game don't hate the game I'm
blaming you hate the player I do hate
you this is a really interesting
technique that you have the one that you
were telling me to do or you just run
through the whole level yeah yeah it's
called the coward technique this is
before you're a
man but after you're a cub so you're
allowed to totally cowered out all right
the bats are going to come after
you you
done all right we got five continues so
we're
okay but I am going to save State just
so that we don't lose any oh should I
just load it up then I don't believe you
he was right
yeah also it's why to attack by the way
I'm
bored oh yeah the old Squat and
[__] that's a
technique oh my God that
acid come here see you can't even attack
it in the air get get away from me get
away from me
oh my God I'm never going to make it I'm
not going to make it let me see let me
see we're going to trade off this last
time what do you mean for this last time
no for this last level oh this is our
last level we're not going to have much
time left if I beat
it got hit on the first acid thanks Mary
you're so supportive I love playing
video games with you it's really fun
Huna
matuna Matata it this is I think
actually the hardest level in the game
um there's other hard levels after this
there's um this is the elephant's
Boneyard is after this and it's like
basically a giant Maze of tunnels and
it's really hard to uh navigate and it
genuinely is a puzzle you have to go
back and forth in between these caves
and there's like eight options that all
lead to death uh and then there's like
one option that
actually results in you succeeding
through the level it's really hard and
like there's so many things that they
make on purpose really difficult that
bat's going to kill you like there's um
in the tunnel level in the in the
Boneyard level you cannot go through a
tunnel unless you've killed all the
animals in the level so if there's four
hyenas you actually have to kill every
hyena just to just to move on and it's
really
irritating oh bat B bat die oh God
all right I'm going to make it through
at least make it through this
section all right I'm doing okay come
here oh my God I can't believe he got me
all right so there's some bats coming up
bats and acid and lava
and oh I missed
him they're so stupid Oh that's the roll
that I'm telling you about if they get
tired you can roll them it's actually
how you beat the game as well um because
the very last level uh you cannot kill
scar just by hitting him you have to uh
roll him off the edge of the cliff
that's how you win and uh oh you mother
effer oh my
God where is the Save State honestly the
checkpoint
oo I didn't know this
existed oh my God I didn't know that was
there just another benefit
of I was waiting for you to hit load
state that was going to make me really
happy oh no so many
bats oh my God there's lava everywhere
lava and
bats like give it a freaking
give it a freaking rest we have time for
one more attempt all right so make it
count all
right oh it's going really well it's off
to a great start get that bug will give
you health yeah but I'm going to take
out this [__]
first
these bats these
bats oh my
God there's a an even more difficult
part coming up I see you I see
you all right so this
um oh that should hurt me there's a save
state right here I just have to knock
that down and then one of the most
difficult Parts in the game is coming up
so I will save it
and okay oh son of a bat all right here
we go save so you can go to the right
that's totally an option but then you
don't get this Save State and I'm
honestly going to say you need that
freaking Save State it's a checkpoint
it's a checkpoint you've been calling
goddamn save states this whole time I've
let it pass I'm going to continue I know
I know you don't subscribe to what
things are called
normally oh God
God this is really
hard but luckily I'm really good oh
no so you're probably thinking to
yourself Mary why aren't you beating
this normally and the answer is is
because you have to get that island and
it's more
important to get that Island than to
continue oh my God that that was
so
good a
we why are there Bowers in this game
it's not once not once is there a
bowler in the
movie If there is I've never seen
it get up
there we
go
one more of
these oh my God that could have killed
me I'm going just smack you from over
here stupid smack
smack smack smack smack smack you just
got smacked smack smack smack
smack smack attack wow all right
so we're going for as long as you
survive you could beat the game on this
one life if I beat the game you guys on
this one life you guys will keep let me
keep playing cuz I know how to beat this
boss and when I mean boss I mean lava
cuz that's sound of a
monkey that's really all this is so all
you have to do is avoid rocks in lava
for like I think like 10 turns maybe so
as this
happens um there's tops that fall onto
the lava shooting
things and then oh and that's it that's
how you win okay um but I think a lot of
it I they wanted it to be is the
difficulty in figuring that out it's
really easy to figure out
but so oh my gosh and you you can get
hit by lava easily or rocks you know it
happens
all right so there's Lids on these so
these are safe now so there should be a
lid on that one coming up real
soon and then a lid on the left
one I
won am the
shizel I think I won I don't know if the
game thinks you won there we go there
you go okay so this is this is I think
this is the confusing one this is the
one that has a puzzle yep so you'll
notice there's like seven different
there's what five and then those turn
into different Pathways and all the
pathways are so confusing it's actually
really hard to beat um but I cheated
last night and looked up the correct
path because it's really hard and it's I
believe you go in this one go I don't
know how to go in forgotten how to go in
there we go
so you have to kill
every and
uh NPC to be able to move on so I
wouldn't have been able to go in this
tunnel if I didn't kill that guy oh this
is really annoying go in the tunnel
Simba
no what is the what do you actually
press to go in I I just Spam until it
works out I've learned
nothing all right
I actually still don't remember all of
the pathways so far I haven't had a
choice but I will really
soon
so oh you mother I'm going to smack you
one
good oh no don't knock me off the edge
it knocked me off the ledge all right
I'm running out of Health here but I'm
okay get up there
stupid get in your
hole get in the
hole I don't want you to double
SWAT I've learned
nothing get in
there you don't just press up no it
makes him SWAT shut up here all right
all
right they're going to attack
me you came out of
nowhere I think there's one more nope
that's it okay I actually don't remember
where to go I
think I think it's this one cuz it's the
one you don't expect you'd expect it to
be like that one but I think it's this
one I'm going to I'm going to stake it
I'm going to call it press
Up
Smack smack smack smack smack smack
smack smack
smack I pressed up oh I'm not facing the
right way yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right this is right so this is
good I actually don't know what to do
can you just take the hit and go through
him I suppose
no thank you for
falling damn it that guy hit me like
three times I lost so much life and the
final state of this battle is I believe
you have
to
shoot I don't remember it's one 50/50
chance it's one of these I'm going to
say if you're in the wrong one where
does it send you it's it might even
freaking send me out like to the
beginning quiet
Peter okay that was the wrong one I'm at
the beginning the very beginning that's
correct all right well at least you
don't have to kill those guys anymore
right you're done I have to kill them
all over
again
Sega I have to basically do do the whole
thing again but now I know that I take
the left tunnel not the right tunnel
imagine doing that like 20 times because
you're a dumb kid you're a dumb kid and
you forget which tunnel there is and
there's no internet to look up I mean
there is but it's filled with creepy
people and it's just a frightening place
to be at that
State can't believe I haven't died yet
get in your
home like I want so much to go in there
but I
can't Oh wrong way die die die die die
oh my God I'm going to
die that's it you put on a great show
but that's it did I die I think he died
is that the end I think he died is that
the
end all right all right production says
one more shot we're giving her one more
shot hey Peter your
happiness is like so much like like
sadness yeah how some truth to that do
your family and friends know I don't
have any family and friends
anymore they've all left my life they'
they've abandoned me you know much like
The Lion King you can actually come back
once you're a man once I've made it
through Lava and the Boneyard and
Stampede you can come back they'll let
you all
right
all
right I fell on you good suck
it all right I'm good this one is going
really well I feel really good about
this smash Max Max Max Max ma Max Max ma
yeah you both stay over there that's
fine it's fine by me all right full
health doing good do you want to save
the state before you choose a door
no in into the right that was the one
you went into before this is right oh
okay oh was right when you get the
choice of two oh no no no no no no no no
no
idiot what an
idiot B oh my
God they're save states or like they're
oh my gosh I can't believe that this is
allowed this is a glitch
jump
stupid jump so I can smack you
on all right all right so I did the
right one last time or did I do the left
one I think you went the right one I
think I went in the right one so this
time we'll choose the left
one and this is the end um this is like
a boss fight I suppose you could call it
because there's like a hundred of them
Jesus I know it's really
annoying
oh you son of a monkey die
die die die die die die die oh man oh
man I'm going to do it with Brute
Force come here oh my God that's it
tricked you he tricked you that's it oh
he got
you did you say haha I
did I'm GNA do it oh no I got it Peter
you're such a naysayer hey
whatever this is the
last chop chop chop chop chop all right
so there's not too much left I'm doing
pretty
good Peter you
nay smack smack oh no that was bad smack
smack smack smack all right I really
don't like how he does this this is 100%
a glitch
jump you got to tease him out oh I still
got
hit all right all right here we
go contain your excitement Peter yeah
contain don't worry I'm good at that
contain it good like Christmas mourn die
die die die
die oh my gosh I like almost need to
separate them oh
oh why are they all
jumping I did it is that it you got it I
did it good
job all right so this is the final
level I'm Gonna Save the game not load
it this is oh there he is that's it he
just fight Scar and that's it no no
there's a whole level um but you have to
like so this is actually kind of good
game design it's teaching you how you
can attack him so now that he's panting
he's he's able to be flip it alude and
that's how you win so I think it's it's
early on training you to to flip him cuz
you have to flip him to win the
game so I think that's what that's all
about oh my God
my
God where are you scar come out fight me
you killed my dad I hate
you hate you you're not my real
dad you're bad
man he's got a block State that's kind
of cool he's he can block see
that there you go so that's how you flip
him it's kind of a spammy thing you kind
of hit like down and backwards and B a
lot and you just flip
him okay I love how I do a flip in the
air if it's not impressive enough that
this lion can hang from ceilings I can
do a flip in between each
run he's in fire he should really be
dead
well sorry
kids all right no
hyenas all right all right jump earlier
than you think is
necessary am I supposed to hit that
ledge or what hit the bludge on fire
yeah I can't even remember doesn't look
right does
it well that's what I did take it on the
chin
all
right can I get that I'm not going to
get it I wouldn't risk it it's not worth
it cuz you know what I'll just freaking
cheat all right I'm doing good you
guys everyone knows that lions are
terrified of
fire smack
you
all right cool doing pretty
good
fire my gosh I am such a good lion die
die die so I'm Ming him
good and then you smack him around so he
knows that you're the boss woo trying to
smack my butt how many rounds you have
to fight him give me that butt scar I'm
gonna get that butt give me that butt
give me that butt scar I'm going get it
oh he's he's such a finicky
lady he makes you earn it you you
appreciate it more if they don't let you
have it right away yeah it's true here
sky as with
women
Sky all right so I'm pretty close uh all
I got to do is there's this little area
I have to kind of
climb
oh
no tried to knock me off the ledge all
right so I'm pretty close now I just got
to climb this and I believe there's some
lightning up
ahead seems like God's against you at
this
point oh my God I freaking hate I hate
this freaking part
it's the controls are so
sensitive everything's on fire
everything is on
fire every everything's on fire where do
you it went out for a second you got to
just give it like a few seconds come on
game so cruel I'm so close to beating
the Lion King if only this fire would go
out when you were down on that ledge
before it went out well not all the way
when I fell
is
that uh-huh you can't climb oh my God he
can that was really
impressive all right I'm pretty
close that fire sounds like farts it
does
oh
no
no everything kills you come on
man can't you jump down there yeah there
you
go
okay can I beat
scar with one hit box that's the
question cuz I'll save it right now you
should save it
right we've come this far I've come so
far I'm sorry we've come this far oh
yeah I forgot about the
teamwork oh he almost got me he booted
me you got you all right all right you
get one more chance all right here we go
one
more all right load State cuz I want to
see it happen otherwise I would have
called this a long time does it does
happen and I it's I've o I've really
appreciated you allowing me to be here
I totally believe everything you just
said it sounded very sincere so good at
booping me one the it's really hard to
like do it without getting hit
once I
think I think this is going to
take so
much so much work don't you worry guys
we all have a lot of faith in
you go
away
that followup man he's pretty strong the
one he is the boss he's the big boss
okay for real is your last try but it's
the
final we have one point left I can't
believe
that he's going after my butt he too
wants to get that butt this is honestly
a battle of who gets that butt scar I'm
coming after that that butt oh my God he
got my
butt we're going to be here all day
folks I can do this I just can't let him
jump or hit
me it's good it's good I can't I can't
get hurt even
once all
right
watch
out I
like feel
like just like when you say you don't
believe in fairies every time a fairy
dies every time Peter doesn't think I
can do this I'll never make it so I need
you to clap your hands
Peter so that I know that you believe
this is not Peter Pan I'm
sorry I need you to
believe I need you to believe oh man I
wish I had one more at what point did I
lose control over this stream I wonder I
need one
more see he gets me that followup every
time I don't know what to do differently
do you want to try take on scar
all right this is absolutely the last
try we can win the
game you have to just when he knocks you
off make sure you go backwards not
forwards so CU if you keep doing that
he's going to hit you again all
right he's going to
jump oh no that's it I'm calling wow
scar really got that but butt didn't he
scar got my butt all right Mary you did
put on a great show you're good you're
good at this game most of the Lion King
I'm really close to beating it yeah it's
a shame uh well I'm talking she'll keep
trying uh thanks for watching Everybody
thanks for sticking with us we did
pretty good Mary did very good she did
very well uh Stupid scar come back next
Monday for more meab bit uh maybe I'll
try to get my hands on Aladdin and see
if you want to come back yeah I would
definitely Aladdin I can do as well and
I can probably beat what's
that I got you yeah and bro Force at 2:
p.m. will be playing multiple players 2
p.m. come back for bro force on multiple
players I said things I said sha
McKinnis is taking place at Chris
Waters thank you for watching thank you
for
watching all right take care everyone
honest to God
I'm
w